okay so we're trying to find the
equation of the normal to the tangent of
this function at this particular point
now to answer this question the first
most obvious thing you need to know is
what is a normal a dog looks very
similar to a tangent it's related to the
tension actually so if you know what a
tangent is you can define the normal so
what's a tangent again comes from gifu
if you remember it comes from the latin
word 10 yeah where we get the word
tangible which means just touching right
so for instance if you graph it looks
like this then a tangent is going to
just touch the curve at the point where
it's touching okay so like that point
there right there the tangent and the
function itself I share the same
gradient and of course they say they
share that point as well okay now what's
the normal what's its relationship to
the tangent it's it's gonna be going
through the same point but instead of
being equal to the gradient it's going
to be perpendicular okay so you're gonna
get a 90 degree angle there okay
so how does that affect what we're going
to do very simply it'll be just like
working the ad the tangent but with one
difference namely that the gradients not
going to be the same we're just going to
take the negative reciprocal okay
so let's give it a at this question
there's a point supplied to you here so
there's my x value 3 and my Y value 6 if
they don't give you that and they'll
give you some other kind of information
to pin down exactly where they want the
normal to be okay so we want to work out
the gradient at that point and then take
the negative negative reciprocal so as
usual we'll use the derivative to do
that so this is why there is a pretty
simple derivative 2x minus 1 so I can
say the x-coordinate x equals 3 right
the grady of the tangent is going to be
so sum 3 in i'm going to get 6 minus 1
so that is five okay so there's the
gradient of the tangent so therefore the
gradient of the normal
is going to be the negative reciprocal
so say minus one over five okay now by
the way just as a small note because
you're going to talk about all these
different gradients in the gradient
function I think it's important to
actually label what they are so you
don't just have random numbers flying
around okay now that you know the
gradient of the normal now you just have
to put it into the equation for or
before for the equation which is I'm
quite grateful right so the equation of
their normal will be given by this we
already know it x1 y1
r63 and that grain of the normal is
going to come in here now you could
expand I suppose but it's kind of neat
to have it in in general form often
that's the best way to present so I'm
going to multiply through by minus five
which will give me minus three and then
I'll tidy up just by breed every thing
on to one side so it's going to become X
plus five - okay now this equation I'm
done with the question but just to check
I mean you know they might have asked us
to do a pretty ordinary thing to ask is
to not just find the equation but to
graph it even if you don't get asked to
graph it it's kind of handy just to draw
yourself a rough sketch so you know
you're in the right ballpark so what
does this equation look like you
factorize that's X X minus one so it's a
parabola and it's going to go through
zero and one those are the intercepts
okay now this point in three six one two
three I'm like quit saying okay now
that's what the problem looks like so
that's my point up there three six now
what did I already know about it well
the grading of the normal is going to be
minus 1/5 now does that sort of match up
with what I'm gonna have yeah I think it
does because this is kind of sky rocking
his getting steeper and steeper see but
so therefore this is kind of the
equation of the normal that I office so
it's in the right ballpark just to
verify and that's actually the equation
that I want so just to review how do you
find the equation of the normal in much
the same way you find the equation of
the tangent so differentiate so you can
find the gradient at a specific point
find the gradient at the point you're
after and then take the negative
reciprocal since you want that
perpendicular okay and then proceed as
you normally would put it into a point
great form and simplify out to get your
equation